on l'a kétal common lv2 bagnole mais ces
dates cette vidéo m'angoisse d'avant
souvenez vous la dernière fois on a fait
une vidéo sur un sobre et dit qui m'a
stressé le cul c'est sûr j'ai des
cheveux blancs maintenant j'en avais
déjà en plus d'une magnifique
implantation cette vidéo je vous le dis
elle a éveillé ma curiosité genre j'ai
fait le tour de tous les sports ou de
toutes les activités au sens plus large
qui sont un peu extrême un peu
sensationnelle mais les humains on est
des d'orgue home et d houphouet je meurs
compris le mérite de ce qu'ose faire des
trucs comme ça et alors ce qui a éveillé
ma curiosité sur ce sujet-là plus
particulièrement c'est la fameuse vidéo
dans la cavité hardcore là dans le sobre
est dite ou s'est plaint de tout petits
conduit minuscules ou pour passer tes
comme ça ils te fasse et je pense qu'ils
avaient pas besoin d'être clos se trouve
à moi je suis pas claustrophobe et ça
m'angoisse de fou s'est classé au delà
de la claustrophobie là c'est là c'est
aimer se faire peur suite à cette vidéo
là en particulier je me suis renseigné
beaucoup du coup sûr la spéléologie et
c'est un game incroyable et qui est très
très grand il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont passionnés savent tout et ça
m'intéresse de découvrir les passions
des autres même si je les comprends pas
forcément j'adore j'ai atterri aussi sur
des histoires de plongeurs extrêmes les
plongeurs extrême c'est des gens qui
plonge très profond dans l'eau et bref
j'ai trouvé une histoire de spéléologues
cafom est une histoire de plongeurs qui
est folle et aujourd'hui je vous
racontais les deux parce que je trouve
qu'elles sont femmes tout d'abord je
vais vous raconter l'histoire de john
edward jones elle est horrible elle fait
partie de ces histoires où on sait déjà
imaginé que c'était arrivé mais on s'est
dit non ça doit aider les gens je
pensais jamais arrivé si si c'est arrivé
john dès son enfance il va avec son
frère josh visiter des cavités
souterraines
rapidement ils sont tous les deux pris
d'affection pour cette activité et en
plus ils en font en étant enfant ce qui
est très pratique puisque c'est avant la
croissance donc tes petits fin et tu
passe partout bref le temps passe il
passe beaucoup on est en novembre 2009
john a maintenant 26 ans il a une femme
il a un enfant est latent même un
deuxième enfant il est en vacances avec
sa famille et des amis et johnny se dit
ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas
fait un petit tour la de spéléologie
dans des cavités souterraines
il se dit que ça peut être une bonne
idée pour passer du temps avec ses amis
à sa famille et du coup ils en trouvent
une qui n'est pas loin du tout la nuti
petit km
alors pour le moment rien de bizarre
dans la spéléologie c'est un truc très
répandue il ya des tas de cavités
souterraines de toutes tailles qui
existent j'en ait des gens qui n'ont
aucune expérience comme vous et moi
peuvent visiter sans mettre leur vie en
danger fin bref c'est pas forcément un
truc qui est dangereux à faire mais
johnny les habitués et lui
bien peu d'être très étroit un peu chaud
à explorer c'est vraiment ça sa passion
maintenant je vous parlais de la multi
putty kf qu'est ce que c'est une très
grande cavité souterraine avec plein le
conduit qui vont dans tous les sens il
ya carrément une map les conduit portent
des noms on voit clairement sur la mappe
s'ils sont durs ou pas à passer ce qui
est fort bec la new type qu'icade c'est
qu'il y en a pour tout le monde à
l'intérieur ça veut dire que quelqu'un
de novice peut se retrouver dans un
passage réservé aux gens expérimentés
sont trop s'en rendre compte du coût en
seulement quelques années il ya eu 10
sauvetage organisé pour venir en aide à
des personnes étant restés bloqués à
l'intérieur derrière en 2006 fut-elle
suite d'incidents les autorités décident
de fermer l'endroit avant de le re
ouvrir trois ans a pris en 2009 et de
réguler les visites on né le 24 novembre
2009 et john décide de se rendre là bas
avec tout un groupe d'amis et des
membres de sa famille dont son frère
josh après 1h d'exploration john tombe
face à une cavité très étroites qu'ils
supposent être un passage qui s'appelle
le beurre ce canal il est indiqué sur la
map
et c'est un passage réservé aux gens qui
sont assez expérimentés justement
puisqu'il est très étroit et tend les
bras et commence peu à peu à s'enfoncer
dans le passage après quelques secondes
jeunes se retrouvent bloqués il n'arrive
plus du tout a bougé et il est coincé
dans une cavité qui fait 45 cm de large
pour 25 cm de haut
c'est extrêmement étroits il faut savoir
que dans ce genre d'endroit en fait t'as
des espaces beaucoup moins étroits que
celui dans lequel john se trouve
actuellement sauf qu'ils sont reliés
entre eux par des passages très étroit
donc john naturellement il se dit bon je
vais forcer je vais essayer d'aller plus
loin comme ça je vais atterrir dans un
endroit un peu plus large et puis
ensuite sur le retour ça devrait mieux
se passer pour ce faire et décide
d'expirer le plus possible et de retenir
sa respiration pour que sa cage
thoracique se rétrécissent grâce à cette
technique il arrive a légèrement avancé
sauf qu'en reprenant son souffle sa cage
thoracique s'élargit de nouveau et là il
se retrouve définitivement bloquée et la
john comprend quelque chose qui fait
vraiment chier
il n'est pas du tout dans le beurre ce
canal il est dans un tout petit conduit
qui est juste à côté et qui est en fait
une impasse étant bloquée naturellement
il appelle son frère khaled qui le
rejoint rapidement
josh voit les pieds de son frère dépassé
d'une qualité qu'elles n'ont pas à
l'horizontale met à la verticale
c'est à dire que john à la tête vers le
bas josh est son frère et il lui prend
les pieds et les tire vers le haut
ça va soulever john de quelques
centimètres et va réussir à mettre ses
bras en arrière et à s'appuyer contre
les parois pour essayer de remonter
malheureusement dans la manipulation
josh relâche jobs qui s'enfonce un peu
plus loin qu'il l'était déjà
cette fois les bras
l'arrière contre son corps il est
complètement bloquée et josh a beau
tirer sur ses jambes il ne se passe rien
john lui demande alors de se rendre à la
surface pour aller chercher les secours
et le sortir de là la première
secouristes à arriver sur les lieux
s'appelle suzy mottola elle arrive sur
les lieux au niveau des pieds de jon
trois heures et demie après -selon 3h30
coincé dans une cavité en arrivant elle
se présente à john et john la supplie de
l'aider à sortir de là parce qu'il n'en
peut plus suis il rassure et lui promet
qu'il finira la journée à la surface et
que ce sera plus qu'un mauvais souvenir
en revanche c'est un truc que suzy elle
dit pas c'est qu'elle est très inquiète
de la position dans laquelle est coincé
jobs le corps humain n'est pas fait pour
fonctionner la tête à l'envers ce qui
fait que john a en gros 24 heures devant
lui avant de s'évanouir est décédé des
suites de l'accumulation de sang dans sa
tête et toxines dans le sang suzie va
travailler d'arrache-pied avec plus de
100 secouriste qui sont rendus sur les
lieux et dans la cavité pour mettre en
place un système pour sortir john de la
cie vont faire c'est assez fou c'est
qu'ils vont percer des trous dans la
paroi rocheuse pour y mettre des poulies
est monté tout un système avec une corde
qui permettrait de tirer john très fort
dans une bonne direction et le sortir du
trou après plusieurs heures toutes les
poules y sont posées toutes les cordes
sont sur les poulies qui compte jusqu'à
3 et il tire de toutes leurs forces sur
le bout de la corde mais ils font face à
un imprévu
l'une des poulies cède et tombe et c'est
pas qu'ils ont mal travaillé c'est que
les murs de cette cavité contiennent
énormément d'argile fragile
du coup c'est hyper dur de fixer un truc
dans la roche et qui restent fixés si on
tire dessus
john respire de plus en plus fort il est
complètement en panique laissant
secouristes continuent de tenter le tout
pour le tout pour sortir john de là mais
malheureusement après 27 heures de
travail
john s'évanouit et succombe de ses
blessures après cet incident la note
hippiques heil a été scellée au béton et
le corps de john repose toujours à
l'intérieur dans cette fameuse cavité
qu'il a pris pour le beurre ce canal
mais qui était en fait un cul de sac
beaucoup trop étroit pour passer au
travers
voilà l'histoire de john en fait ce qui
est horrible c'est que il lui est
vraiment arrivée l'un de mes cauchemars
mais plus grand cauchemar de rester
bloqué dans un truc et que personne
n'arrive à me débloquer que je décède
c'est pas un truc expéditif où tu tombe
sur la tête et on en parle plus et tu
est coincé tu es seul de l'autre côté de
toi il ya des gens qui s'étaient battus
peut même pas les voir tous étaient dans
le noir tout seul à être juste à tête
contre un caillou et tu peux rien faire
à part compter sur les gens qui sont là
pour tt son histoire à john haley elle
est touchante parce qu'il a vraiment eu
pas de chance en fait déjà il confond un
passage connu du truc par un cul de sac
inexploré et beaucoup trop étroit pour
être explorées et ensuite il a fait sa
manipulation avec sa cage thoracique
qu'il a un peu trop enfoncé et qu'il a
complètement
baiser parce que ça l'a mis dans un
angle ou les secouristes pouvait rien
faire c'est terrible en vrai ya très peu
de gens en spéléologie qui sont décédés
en restant coincé mais ça reste une
pratique et à haut niveau est
extrêmement dangereuse et john il en a
payé le prix fort c'est terrible bref
voilà cette histoire c'est juste pour
justifier un peu ma la pression que j'ai
eu face à cette vidéo la dernière fois
là c'est totalement justifié et tous
ceux qui n'auraient ressorti vous êtes
des bourses d'accord ou vous avez un
poil plus de courage hockey
maintenant je vais vous raconter une
deuxième histoire qui est incroyable
c'est celle d'un plongeur david chow
alors vous le savez j'ai découvert en
même temps pas mal de gens parmi vous
j'ai la thalasso phobie thalasso phobie
c'est quand tu es dans l'eau et que tu
vois pas ce qu'il y'a parce que l'eau
n'est pas du tout transparente et du
coup tu as très peur c'est thalasso
phobie fait qu'à l'été 2010 9 je suis
allé faire de la plongée dans la mer
j'ai fait le baptême classique pas une
formation dengue dont je suis descendu
jusqu'à 12 mètres mais ça m'a vachement
réconcilier en fait avec ma peur des
fonds marins et de ce qu'il peut y avoir
dans la mer j'ai plongé dans une eau
claire et j'ai enfin vu ce qu'il y avait
je me suis dit mais en fait j'ai
trop peur pour rien ça suffit j'en ai
marre d'avoir peur pour rien avant de
vous parler de l'histoire de da
hockey incroyable
il faut donc que je vous parle de ce que
c'est que la plongée en profondeur la
vraie profondeur en gros dans la
communauté des plongeurs et à certaines
personnes qui sont des plongeurs en eau
profonde c'est une communauté qui est
minuscule et son genre une douzaine sur
la planète
en gros c'est des gens qui veulent
repousser les limites humaines en allant
toujours plus profond je sais pas de
quand datent les chiffres exactement il
a peut-être de quelques années entre
temps il ya des gens qui ont commis cet
exploit encore et encore mais j'ai
checké un peu partout et en fait il ya
que cette personne qui ont plongé en
dessous de 250 mètres de profondeur
c'est à dire qu'il ya plus de mecs qui
sont allés sur la lune que deux mecs qui
sont allés en dessous de 250 mètres dans
la mer c'est incroyable sans compter
évidemment tous ceux qui sont allés en
sous-marin lâche pas vraiment que de ce
qu'on plonge avec des bouteilles pour
ceux qui connaissent pas la plongée et
les contraintes que cela implique je
vais vous donner deux trois teasers faut
comme ça vous les prenez vous les mettez
sous la dent et on passe à l'histoire de
david shaw en gros les êtres humains on
est capable de faire des équipements qui
peuvent aller très profond mais ils ne
garantissent en rien le fait que ton
corps va résister à ces profondeurs
déjà quand tu plonges à des profondeurs
comme ça ta visibilité elle est hyper
réduite parce qu'il fait noir
alors évidemment tu es une lampe pour
éclairer mais il ya un réel risque que
tu te perde ou que tu reste bloqué en
plus de ça pour pouvoir respirer sous
l'eau on emmène avec nous des bouteilles
de gaz et dans ses bouteilles à un
mélange de trois gars ce qu'on appelle
trimix yade zélium de la zot et de
l'oxygène
évidemment le problème c'est que ce
mélange de gaz sur lequel repose ta
survie il peut te tuer tout simplement
déjà plus tu es en profondeur plus là
zot agit comme un narcotique
en gros plus t'es bourré ce qui est
parfaitement injuste puisque plus tu
m'as profond est en danger mais
plus tu perds la tête et est moins
capable de prendre des décisions
l'hélium que ya dans ce mélange de gaz
lui il peut provoquer des crises de
nerfs et ensuite si tu respires pas
profondément et calmement le dioxyde de
carbone il s'accumule dans son organisme
et tu peux tu évanouir et donc de noyer
et enfin le risque majeur quand tu fais
de la plongée vous connaissez tous
croient lemancel accident de
décompression en gros quand tu
la plongée plus tu es profond plus la
pression est élevée du coup pour éviter
un accident de décompression selon la
profondeur à laquelle est allé un
plongeur il doit respecter tout un tas
de paliers de décompression c'est à dire
rester à certaine profondeur un certain
temps avant de rejoindre la prochaine
profondeur du coup les mecs qui
descendent à 240 m leurs paliers de
décompression c'est des heures qu'ils
doivent attendre
c'est énorme je n'ai pas qu'il y avait
autant de temps d'attendre pour pouvoir
remonter dites vous que c'est tellement
long que sur ce genre d'expédition le
long de la ligne guide quelle ligne
placée à la verticale qui te sert de
repère il attache des paniers avec
dedans de la bouffe et de l'eau comme ça
quand le garde ou attendre deux heures
et demie à 30 mètres de profondeur il
peut se taper son petit weeks
tranquillement faut savoir qu'il ya deux
systèmes pour faire de la plongée et ça
a son importance puisque show utilise le
système que vous et moi roux connaît pas
il ya les bouteilles hyperbare classics
et les bouteilles que vous allez
utiliser vous si vous faites un baptême
de plongée là dans les semaines à venir
en gros c'est un système ouvert
c'est-à-dire que quand tu inspires
t'inspire ce qu'il ya dans la bouteille
quand expire sa part dans l'eau donc ça
fait des bulles qui parle dans l'eau
tout est automatique tu as déjà de quoi
survivre dans la bouteille a rien à
surveiller niveau dosage
le deuxième système que je connaissais
pas et que je trouve tout ça s'appelle
le recycleur le recycleur c'est un
système qui peut être à circuit fermé
c'est à dire que tu relâches jamais
d'air dans l'eau n'y a jamais eu de
bulle l'avantagent du coup c'est que tu
as besoin de moins de bouteilles de gaz
puisque tu recycle l'oxygène que tu
rejettes bref ça c'est le haut niveau
vous et moi on recyclera jamais notre
oxygène sous l'eau on prend les
bouteilles classiques et franchement
pour aller à 12 mètres elle nous vont
très bien david chow c'est un fan de
plongée et lui ce qu'il veut c'est pété
les records en octobre 2004 il décide
d'aller plonger dans le boesmans gâte
elle est située en afrique du sud et
c'est la plus grosse grotte d'eau douce
jamais découvertes puisqu'elle fait 280
mètres de profondeur le mec est allé
plus profond à cet endroit la ceni nos
gomes huit ans auparavant en 1996 et les
descendu à 2 183 mètres de profondeur
l'objectif de david chow il est simple
c'est de le record de nos courses
aux bêtes il veut juste nique et les
autres bref chaussée bien préparé ce
jour-là y descend et il touche le fond
de la cavité
il est à 270 m elle se détache de la
ligne guide pour explorer un peu les
environs faut savoir que chaque minute
qu'il passe à cette profondeur lui
oblige une heure de décompression en
plus quand il va vouloir remonter à la
surface
shawn âge il balaie sa lumière de gauche
à droite est là il tombe sur un corps il
n'y a pas 36 mais qui sont décédés ici
donc il sait très bien qu'ils aient
score c'est celui de john dreyer c'est
un nageur qui avait la vingtaine et qui
s'est évanoui dix ans plus tôt à la même
under que celle où show est actuellement
le corps est squelettique mais damon
porte toujours sa tenue de plongée il a
toujours son masque de plongée et il a
toujours ses bouteilles avec lui chaumet
ses bras autour de la dépouille
ils essaient de la soulever sauf qu'elle
est complètement attaché à la boue 10
heures plus tard show est de retour à la
surface
il a réussi sa mission il est allé plus
profond que personne ne l'ait jamais été
ici et il regarde son pote scheer les
élus dit j'ai trouvé le corps de d1
on va aller chercher le sortir de leur
nouvel objectif
il est accro aux records vous savez il
ya cette tradition entre guillemets ou
quand quelqu'un décède il faut ramener
le corps à la famille et la chaux il est
exactement dans ce délire là il se dit
je veux être le héros qui ramène à des
parents le corps de leur fils décédé à
10 ans bref shoichi relais vont bosser
pendant des mois sur ce qu'ils vont
appeler ce big five pour transporter le
corps ciao décide que la meilleure
solution c'est de le mettre dans un sac
mortuaire qu'il confectionne lui même
sinon il risque de se disloquer et se
rendre à l'acte beaucoup moins héroïque
thuram est pas un corse il manque les
jambes ou enfin ces fichiers céchi
relais qui met au point le plan de
plongée et il est parfaitement orchestré
faut savoir que quand tu plonges à des
profondeurs comme ça ça rigole 0 la
plongée durera 12 heures à cause des
paliers décompression tout au long de la
ligne guide se trouveront sept plongeurs
de soutien dont scheer les haies sont là
pour aider chaud en cas difficulté et
pour se passer l'un à l'autre le sac
mortuaire dans lequel est censé se
trouvait la dépouille de des autres il
place 35 bouteilles de gaz d'appoint
c'est assez pour que lui chaut et même
certains plongeurs de soutien puisse
survivre en cas de panne totale d'un
recycleur bref tout est prêt et chaud
est déterminé à marquer l'histoire
il est tellement des terres qu'ils
appellent un réalisateur de film et qui
lui dit frérot on va marquer l'histoire
tu devrais faire un documentaire sur dix
et met au point un boîtier de caméras
capables de résister à des grandes
profondeurs et ce boîtier sera fixé à la
tête de chaud le jour de son exploit la
veille de l'expédition chez les demandes
quand même à son ami s'il souhaite
qu'ils descendent l'aider si j'avais
voit qu'il est dans le mal
show lui réponds oui mais uniquement si
lui fait signe de descendre on est le
jour j il est 6 heures 13 la caméra
tourne show serre la main de chercher et
lui dit adam 20 minutes et saute à l'eau
onze minutes plus tard chaud ou touche
le fond du beau ce mondial il se met à
suivre la ligne secondaire qui l'avait
mis en place lors de leur première
plongée et qu'il amène comme prévu face
au corps de deux hommes à la surface
deux minutes plus tard scheer les reçoit
le signal et se met en route pour
loin de show à son point de rendez-vous
à 221 mètres de profondeur scheer les
approches les 152 mètres et aperçoit la
langue de shows en baissant les yeux
sauf qu'il ya un petit souci la lampe ne
bouge pas scheer les comprend tout de
suite que quelque chose ne va pas et
garde son calme et attend le signal de
chaux pour venir l'aider mais le signal
ne vient pas arrivé à 243 mètres de
profondeur scheer les entends un
craquement léger et nette sur son
avant-bras et baisse les yeux et il
constate que son contrôleur numérique
vient de céder sous la pression et
comprend donc que s'ils descendent
rejoint de chaud c'est pour l'éternité
il commence alors sa remontée qui va
durer dix heures après plusieurs minutes
il regarde vers le bas et il constate
que la lumière de chaux et maintenant
éteinte quelques heures plus tard scheer
les atteint le plafond de la chambre à
50 mètres de profondeur mais il commence
à sentir faible chez relay ne le sait
pas encore mais il est remonté trop vite
par conséquent une bulle d'hélium s'est
formé dans son oreille interne il n'a
donc plus aucun équilibre sa vision
commence à s'obscurcir
et il a alors un réflexe qui va lui
sauver la vie il attrape la ligne guide
et s'y rattachent cichy relais n'avait
pas réussi à la rattraper ce jour là et
se serait évanoui et se serait noyé
scheer l'essor de l'eau très mal en
point il tient pas debout
il a des pertes de mémoire il a des
discours incohérents bref c'est la merde
il lui a fallu un mois avant de pouvoir
penser clairement de nouveau et qui
puisse être 100% lucide alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pour chaud et bien déjà
il a réussi sa mission en fait chaud ils
avaient attaché d'eon à la ligne de la
caverne qui était elle même attaché à la
ligne guide du coup quand les plongeurs
sont revenus plusieurs jours après pour
faire remonter la ligne guidées toutes
les bouteilles qui étaient attachées à
des deux flotteurs et ben ils ont aussi
fait remonter le corps de deron ainsi
que le corps de chaud qui était lui
aussi accroché à la ligne de la caverne
on se pose donc tous une question
pourquoi show n'est pas remonté qu'est
ce qui s'est passé eh bien écoutez on le
sait grâce à la caméra qu'il avait sur
la tête sur ces images on le voit
s'approcher du corps de deux hommes
sauf qu'il n'est pas du tout coincé dans
la boue comme la fois d'avant cette fois
il flotte dans tous les scénarios prévus
personne n'avait imaginé que le corps de
john puisse flotter et 7 libérer de la
boue sur les images on entendait de
respirer et on voit que face à cette
surprise ils augmentent sans faire
exprès son rythme respiratoire après
cinq minutes de manipulation qui ne
mènent à rien et décide de retourner
vers la ligne guide
sauf que ce jour là sa lampe de poche
habituellement fixée à son casque était
en fait dans sa main est relié à lui par
une corde et la corde de la lampe s'est
emmêlé à la nuit
de la caverne du coup show ne pouvait
plus avancer vers la ligne guide et dans
son désespoir on voit sortir une paire
de ciseaux et essayer de couper la corde
mais il échoue et s'évanouit à cause de
son rythme respiratoire
c'est beau parce qu'il aura quand même
réussi sa mission qui était de ramener
le corps de damon à ses parents à la
surface
sauf qu'il en est mort du coup ça
vachement fait débat dans la communauté
des plongeurs extrême et beaucoup de
gens disaient que ça valait pas le coup
de se mettre en danger à ce point pour
ramener un corps alors pas voilà c'était
l'histoire un peu glauque de deux amis
aventurier est fan de sports extrêmes
j'espère que ça vous aura plu en tout
cas on ag a pris trop de trucs surtout
sur la partie plongée et ces deux
histoires qui était très longue surtout
celle de david mais je sais pas j'ai été
vachement pris par ce truc là et je vous
dis la vérité j'ai envie d'aller faire
de la plongée à 12 m évidemment pas 280
ça vous a plu
dites le moi et je ferai d'autres trucs
sur des histoires de gens un peu
improbable comme ça qui se finissent pas
forcément par une fin tragique comme là
mais je sais pas j'aime bien raconter
des histoires et pour quoi m'en tenir au
trader un je ne sais pas j'avais adoré
aussi raconter l'histoire de advan
migraine la dernière fois et là voilà
c'était david shaw et john edward jones
en tout cas on est tous cas les ont
plongés maintenant on est tous très
forts à les moniteurs de plongée vont
être choqués de notre savoir je vous le
dis portez vous bien à très vite merci
d'avoir regardé
[Musique]